[Music]
how's it going my name's Monte Carlo and
this is Ramsey redemption that's where
you send a photo of some real ugly food
to Gordon Ramsay and then he burns it
and then I stalk him on the Twitter's it
looks like a chicken dish or some sort I
can tell from the caption that says it's
a Mediterranean chicken but it looks
like it's Mediterranean by way of the
strip mall this dish is from Mahoney and
I'm calm okay there is nothing
Mediterranean about this chicken except
maybe the red pepper that chicken looks
like it's been run over what happens
when the chicken crosses the road it
gets burped and dried out like you sir
all right you know what it's time to
redeem this dish first things first
Mediterranean chicken babe you got to
add the flavors of the Mediterranean I'm
talking all it's talking red onion
orange you want the orange okay and you
also want fennel because this is a
little bit licorice flavored and that is
an incredible flavor profile this is a
fabulous array of chicken thighs why
chicken thighs because honey those
breasts that you were working with were
so dried out chicken thighs are marbled
throughout first things first we're
gonna zest this orange zest is where the
flavor is now this is a microplane if
you are used to micro planing your
citrus I don't want to see you do
something like the back and forth okay
that's bananas all right one suggested
this orange like we have just now keep
the zest set it to the side we're gonna
prepare our red onion first cut it in
half through the roots
we're just gonna slice it into quarter
think inch pieces I am making this dish
in a sheet pan because I don't have time
to fuss around after coming home from
work okay so a sheet pan dinner is quick
it's easy where am I gonna put this here
have you seen this before
it's a fennel bulb mmm we are gonna keep
these why because we're gonna use the
fronds as garnish you watch it's going
to be beautiful I love it black licorice
you're gonna take this take that root
end off and then we're gonna slice
fennel is a traditional Mediterranean
flavor they love black licorice flavor
okay look at these awesome slices you
want to slice these really thick
otherwise they're gonna end up burnt now
we're gonna make a marinade we're gonna
take the citrusy notes of the
Mediterranean and put them right into
our chicken not just with lemon but also
with orange so first lemon then a little
garlic because hello garlic
okay then red pepper because you always
want to add a little heat grainy mustard
is so imperative it's okay to use your
hands you wash those right and a little
salt kosher salt please and some fresh
ground black pepper lots of pepper
pepper makes it better it's gonna add
earthiness fabulous orange zest take it
this is gonna go in our onions and in
our fennel you ready to go
all right we're gonna let this marinate
for at least an hour preferably
overnight yes you can make this ahead
and then when you get home from work
assuming you have a job in which case
I'm proud of you you're gonna have the
most easy and amazing sheet pan dinner
yes can you smell the Mediterranean no
cuz you're watching this at home but if
you make it it's gonna take you there we
are going to get this ready for our
sheet pan
these are fingerling potatoes I like to
use these potatoes one they have a lot
of color look at that look at that
beautiful color how amazing is that
gonna look on your sheet pan I like
these because they cook a lot faster
than big old potatoes but you can use a
big old potato if you want just make
sure that you cut it nice and thin okay
sheet pan are usually covered in
aluminum foil for easy cleanup you don't
want to do that when you have citrus or
any kind of acid in your recipe because
then you're gonna end up serving
yourself a big old side
chemicals so if you don't want to clean
up for half an hour afterwards his
parchment paper not wax paper parchment
paper we're gonna take these you're
gonna add a little pepper a little salt
a drizzle of olive oil doesn't get any
more Mediterranean than olive oil take
your veggies out of your marinated
chicken plate and we're gonna put these
on the bottom of the sheet pan so they
don't burn potatoes are gonna get so
nice and crispy and when you put the
chicken on top all of that rendered
chicken fat is gonna soak into your
veggies will you look at the colors on
this platter amazing I got 99 problems
but a bland meal ain't one let's do it
450 degrees for at least a half an hour
until these chicken thighs reach about a
hundred and fifty while your chicken is
in the oven getting all sorts of
redonkulous we are going to prepare this
orange now this is a cara cara Orange
a cara cara Orange is basically just a
regular navel orange but it's got red
flesh we are just going to take the peel
off this orange just carve around it
you're also going to want to make sure
that you get rid of the white stuff okay
that's pretty good
this isn't that the prettiest thing what
is gorgeous about plate that you put out
there
Mahoney these are gonna be ready to go
in just a few minutes we're going to
relay them that just means we're gonna
cook them with a little sugar on top
gonna get golden brown because I'm at
Gordon's house
humble brag I'm gonna go ahead and take
advantage of the fact that he has two
massive ovens and boil these for two or
three minutes and get them all crispy
and golden and amazing that's in there
I'm gonna check on this chicken oh you
guys are gonna love me
meat I give it yes I that's Spanish for
I killed it look okay this chicken looks
amazing while it rests on a platter
we're gonna warm up our olives I'm not
OCD you guys know
black olives green olives alright we're
gonna take our chicken it's been resting
we're gonna take it off the platter
let's place some of our veggies on the
platter I don't mean to sound like a
total Bracker but this already looks a
hundred percent better than what you put
out there Mahoney but that's okay baby
I'm teaching you the tricks pile up the
veggies make sure to show off all those
incredible golden potatoes this is so
colorful you could literally just slap
it on the platter but why would you and
miss that Instagram appointment okay
here we go beautiful beautiful beautiful
[Music]
look at this look at all the color on
this that caramelization is gonna add
acidity a touch of sweetness place it
all careful like oh my goodness
can you believe we made this in a sheet
pan in no time listen we save these
fennel fronds why because they're
gorgeous and they're tasty I hope you're
taking notes Mahoney but in case you're
not I've got the whole recipe for you
below in the description look at this
incredible dish it's quick it's easy and
it's definitely Mediterranean man
Mahoney
look at your dish grab the land it's
Becky with the good hair this my friend
is beyond sick market redeemed let's see
the Gordon thinks this dish really moves
me thank you for watching all the way to
the end of this video and for being a
part of our fabulous redemption family
if you've got a dish that needs
redemption send a picture or a video
with the hashtag Ramsey redemption and
you'll never know I might get a chance
to fix it we smell this Justin just
smell it dude
when you compliment me